okay yeah hello and welcome to this
video playing Grand Master mandragora
Godzilla good friend of mine themselves
let's see what happens we get there I
can actually do this does he still says
what does it say here especially good on
what is he doing now you're not going
for the special because i think it's
like when a frys that's what i remember
yeah so okay I'm just going to make a
draw here it's not great they don't
quite know how to stand i think here and
then i have to take but it's not
something that i really have studied
clean g6 maybe I really don't know this
is not yet something I've looked at I
don't know this is good to be honest
return and maybe I should have just
cancelled Eileen Bishop h3 wouldn't have
been all that terrible then yeah okay
maybe I don't mind the Queen's right
here I think I don't want to take on
them on g6 but still this like standoff
here between the Queen's it doesn't look
too bad so just Jesus Rio on I don't
know is he going 45 here maybe maybe he
is c4 you can just take twice 5555 I can
also i can just take right
so I can take now maybe now is the H
file is of no relevance and so Drago c4
here or not it was my original intention
so let's do it cheeks yeah I'm not
actually sure how I recapture it takes
on sea floor even Bishop takes e4 make
some sense now taking on e6 is a little
bit more interesting than before if that
would really harm spawn structure quite
considerably but I can also play before
in this position I don't see anything
wrong with this idea you know and now
maybe just a five okay
I asked trying to regroup that and
however this gives me the chance to play
a 3 now before it was the tricky because
of the potential takes at d5 this is now
this is now feasible he might try Bishop
b6 to cease fire but it should be six I
can go before that's not not that
probably
and maybe I would go a file and
disposition just prevent before and
still enter should be 65 a 5s sera yeah
that looks that would probably be my
main candidate is taking a while yet so
not an easy easy position to play
what is this some kind of connection
issue now we're both connected it's not
an easy move this should be six it's not
necessarily bad why is he going for
something else entirely so bit weird
that it is extremely long think are you
doing it no there's something wrong
maybe there was the doorbell or I don't
know something that disturbed him now so
now a move at least and yeah I wanted to
go perform in their widows so this one
ok and now I would have caused like to
put more pressure on the a pawn but it's
currently currently not possible
yeah I would assume this is roughly
equal let's go to create I was thinking
just this move which basically traits
trade down I think it will probably take
on be fine
yeah we should be six he just blocking
it no yeah I was thinking we should be
three here to get this pawn rolling from
a structural point of use is pretty
awful but Bishop before so but then f2
Hank so let's let's do it um interesting
I'm should i am moving the light squared
Bishop well he killed he cannot take
twice only three that's not going to
work so maybe this is right and he's
just too slow if he takes to Isis b6 and
I'm promoting you have to react now with
move like that and now I was thinking
look see one maybe is actually attacking
this okay so
[Music]
I completely did not see that this is
actually hanging on the phone that's a
shame time morning just wrong me no way
forward can I place the ship's you fall
you can take to them and they take here
table s7 it's only not not nothin all
that much okay check check check check
check it doesn't help okay I have no way
forward yeah can I go cook you one I
mean I can technically speaking you
should see to it doesn't help it also
offered and i don't know I'm fitted
wrong job might be in it all heartland
game I see no way for an x I really
don't like to press stuff like that on
time against friends so hmm touch them I
felt like this should be somewhat
critical and maybe maybe I'm wrong yeah
so let's start somewhere somewhere here
and see what happened this is where I
think in normal vertical position Castle
is probably more more
testing i guess but yeah i don't i don't
know this line so now yeah now i took 20
form this kind of structure is usually
extremely sound and solid and i think
this is no no real exception so we have
a grind here and here i felt i could
have something and the engine agrees but
how exactly are 93 aha just not take it
oh yeah that makes some sense yeah once
you look at it now and once the engine
pointed out the light year from here
doesn't have any squares currently not
be three c2e2 f3 doesn't doesn't have
money squares and a six remains weak f5
is an interesting suggestion by the
engine because it's probably not so
bright here i'm using grip 93 m and so
this probably isn't isn't all that great
but then the main problem was like to
test this and Bishop e2 I don't know
this is a difference that i actually
have bishop f3 in some situations I just
wanted to yeah put the bishop on a safe
square okay we had this is this yeah I
look see one was the book see one was
wrong it was just the wrong move here I
have to have this banner right
anticipate we should be seven ah that
would have been a lot stronger
yeah this is pretty good this position
is pretty good I'm not sure how does the
engine just gives 0.8 but I don't quite
see how black stops the beep on in the
long run if i get my king involved and
anyway that took very good for white and
sorry what i did i just did not really
have to sure to be seven on the radar as
a it was a good move and this is
probably just a draw oh that was one
moment here king at 87 or even better
for black okay now he didn't have much
time chan chan chan young feel like it's
definitely i said enough i don't have
any chance any great ideas so a draw is
fair yeah I think yeah okay guys thanks
for watching